Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec Yacine !
- Bonjour !
Yacine Belhousse ?
- Bonjour ! Enchanté !
- Yacine Belhousse.
et Fabien Olicard.
J'ai depuis longtemps une envie de croiser le mentalisme et le vaudou.
- Oh, non...!
Et pour ça il me faut un mec, le mec gentil par excellence.
Tu vois ?
- Oh mon dieu !
Et on peut faire du "gentil vaudou" ?
On va faire du gentil vaudou.
[rires]
Déjà on va agresser personne.
On va agresser une petite poupée comme ça.
- Ah ça va !
Elles sont toutes piquées à des endroits différents.
- Oui bien sûr.
Je te le fais voir, et puis je vous le fais voir en même temps.
- Alors il y a des petites tâches de sang quand même...
Oui.
- Voilà, on précise que là il y a eu des petits problèmes.
Alors, il y a une, qui n'est pas à l'intérieur ...
Mais c'est à l'intérieur de cette enveloppe là.
- Ok.
Et alors ça, on verra si le vaudou fonctionne.
On aura peut-être une espèce de synchronicité entre les deux.
- D'accord.
- La peur est en moi actuellement.
La peur est en toi.
Est-ce que tu peux les retourner et les mélanger entre elles ?
- Je peux faire les deux.
Oui.
- Je vais d'abord les mélanger comme ça.
Oui, tu les mélanges.
Je veux que tu ne te souviennes plus de l'ordre des cartes.
- En fait, je n'ai pas trop eu le temps de les mémoriser.
Moi je regarde la caméra pour vous montrer que je n'ai pas eu le temps de pimper dans quel ordre sont classées les cartes.
-Peut-être que toi, tu arrives à, genre, regarder un truc, à t'en souvenir.
Non non , pas du tout.
-Moi déjà j'ai oublié que c'était des poupées.
[rires]
J'ai même oublié ce que je faisais là.
- C'est ça. Je ne sais plus ce que je fais là.
Alors est-ce qu'on voit tout à l'image ? Oui, ça m'a l'air bien.
- Il y a les cartes ici.
On va même les étaler un petit peu.
- Alors 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Oui, il y en a 7.
Pour commencer, on va en choisir une qui sera l'élue.
C'est-à-dire que quoi qu'il arrive on sait qu'il ne va pas lui arriver du mal,
donc tu mets ton doigt sur une des sept cartes.
Celle que tu veux.
Celle-ci, il ne lui arrivera pas de mal, on ne va pas la piquer , on ne va pas la voudouiser.
C'est laquelle que tu nous enlève...
- Ah oui tant mieux.
Là c'est dans le ventre.
- Ou le nombril, ça fait mal.
Donc on enlève celle-ci.
Maintenant, tu vas me faire deux tas de trois cartes.
Choisi les cartes que tu veux.
- Je chipote. C'est capitaine chipotage.
Capitaine chipotage !
C'est bien. Nous avons donc un tas de trois et un second tas de trois cartes.
Tu choisis un paquet de carte, l'un est pile, l'autre sera face, et on va sélectionner à pile ou face.
Pile.
Face.
-Pile.
-Et face.
Et je sors une pièce de 1€.
- Est-ce qu'on peut mettre la musique: "A pile ou face" ?
- C'est la musique parfaite pour ça !
J'ai sorti une pièce de 1€, qui est pile d'un côté et face de l'autre.
Donc tu vas la faire tourner,
et si ça tombe sur pile c'est ce tas là, et si on tombe sur face, on garde ce tas là.
- C'est totalement ça.
On gardera le tas qu'on aura obtenu en fonction fonction de la pièce ?
- Oui c'est ça.
Ok ça marche.
Tu sais la faire tourner comme ça à deux doigts ?
- Je vais essayé, comme dans les saloons.
Tu fais à deux doigts comme ça.
pfiou
- A deux doigts ? Je ne sais pas si je vais réussir à le faire...
-  Moi j'arrive comme ça.
Vas y ! Essaie.
Ah pas mal !
- J'arrive à la faire tourner comme ça.
Ouais c'est pas mal du tout.
- Et c'est pile !
Pile !
Tu avais dis que pile était celui-là.
- Celui-là.
Donc celles-ci on les enlève.
- On peut savoir ce que c'est ?
Pied, tu le ressens un petit peu.
La tête.
- Ah oui tant mieux.
Pour un mentaliste il n'y a pas pire.
Et le cœur.
- Olala ! Tant mieux !
Ca va pour l'instant on ne risque plus grand chose.
Allez, je t'en fait voir deux et t'en élimine une.
- D'accord, ça me va très bien.
Tu élimines celle que l'on va mettre à coté avec les autres. Tu choisis une des deux.
- Alors on élimine celle-là.
On élimine celle avec la main gauche.
C'est la main gauche. La main coté cœur.
Tu élimines tout ce qui est gauche toi ?
- Ouais, tout ce qui est gauche, j'aime pas trop...
- Je suis sourd de l'oreille gauche, donc peut-être que ça vient de là.
Ah oui c'est vrai ?
- Oui c'est vrai, j'ai un problème d'ouïe.
-J'entends comme ça "grougroubrr".
Tu entends un tigre en fait.
- Oui un tigre, qui pilote un avion.
[rires]
-C'est dans le spectacle.
Allez le voir en spectacle.
- Allez LE voir en spectacle.
Tu reprends quand à Paris ?
- J'ai une date le 22 novembre, à l'Européen.
Oh !
Elle est tellement bien cette salle !
-Très belle salle.
C'est la meilleure salle pour faire des stand-up.
- Oui, je suis trop content d'aller là-bas.
Et il a un plateau à la nouvelle scène, et qui reprend le 26 septembre.
- Oui, avec un certain Fabien Olicard.
Oui, je vais tester un nouveau numéro là-bas.
Un essai.
Il ne reste plus que deux cartes, on termine par un pile ou face.
Tu me dis qui est pile et qui est face.
- Tu sais quoi, celle-là, je ne l'aime pas trop...
Et donc ? Du coup ?
Pile.
Face.
Où ai-je mis la pièce ?
- Je ne l'ai pas.
Peux tu répéter s'il te plait ?
- Elle pile, elle face.
D'accord.
Ca c'est face, ça c'est pile.
Alors c'est toujours la même chose,
celle qui tombera sur la pièce sera celle qu'on éliminera.
- Oui, on élimine, au fur et à mesure.
Exactement.
T'as jeté comme...
- Je n'ai pas fait exprès. Je ne sais pas ce que j'ai fait, mais elle a tournée quand même, on est d'accord ?
- Elle a tourné moyennement ?
Non elle n'a pas tourné du tout !
Tu veux que je le fasse ?
- Vas y fait le.
- J'suis chaud !
Ce sera peut-être la même chose...
- Voilà ! Ca c'est stylé, j'avoue !
Tu vois il y a un peu de suspens.
- Oui, il y a du suspens !
Et c'est pile !
- C'est celle-là de toute façon que je n'aimais pas.
C'est vrai ? C'est celle que tu voulais enlever en plus ?
- Oui c'est celle que je voulais enlever.
Oh j'ai eu très très peur quand j'ai vu la petite boule rouge.
Je n'avais pas encore vu le pic en fait au départ. Je n'ai vu que la boule rouge.
- Ah non.
Non c'est douloureux.
C'est le pied droit, donc il n'en reste plus qu'une.
Je ne sais pas si la pièce a été voudouisé, si c'est vraiment tout relié et tout. Je ne sais pas si il y a de la synchronicité.
-Tu dis que la carte correspond à celle dans l'enveloppe ? Mais non ce n'est pas possible !
Alors je ne sais même plus ce que j'ai mis dedans en fait.
J'ai deux jeu de photos comme çà, identiques, et j'en ai mis une au hasard dedans
et je me suis dis qu'on ferait des éliminations avec Yacine, jusqu'au bout.
-C'est le moment où tu me fais peur après, je pense que t'es une sorcière et tout.
On ouvre ?
C'est un bout de carton, tu peux le vérifier, il n'y a que du carton.
Et donc là c'est la main droite qui est piquée.
Tu le sens un peu, il y a un côté Jésus derrière.
C'est la main droite qui a été piquée.
Tu crois que c'est ça derrière ?
-On a pas vu la main droite ?
Non c'est vrai, on a pas encore vu une main droite passée.
-Oh ! Mais non ! Mais n'importe quoi...!
Et si Yacine !
-Mais ça fait peur, c'est une sorcière.
-Oh non !
Il parait que c'est le mec qui joue avec le vaudou, qui se prend les sorts après.
-Ah non, mais je n'étais pas au courant moi.
Je pense même que c'est le seul endroit où tu n'auras pas mal. Et tout le reste va s'abattre sur toi.
-Oh non ! Il ne faut pas dire ça !
[rires]
-Moi je suis superstitieux, je vais y croire.
-C'est trop fort !
Ce tour t'as plu ?
-Ah oui, ça m'a plu mais c'est très flippant.
-Je ne sais même plus comment on en est arrivé là...
-J'ai choisi des cartes...
-Il y a vait la pièce...
Merci beaucoup Yacine Belhousse !
-De rien et merci à toi !
Yacine il part à Montréal, il est juste venu faire la vidéo.
-Oui c'était super, c'était génial, mais c'est énervant parce qu'on ne sait pas comment tu as fait.
Même moi je commence à être énervé parce que j'ai un doute sur le fait que j'ai tout maitrisé.
-Ouais mais laisse tomber, moi je préfère penser que tu as vraiment maitriser parce que sinon ça fait peur.
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
J'espère que ça vous a plu.
Vendredi, je ferai une vidéo où je mentalise quelqu'un de la chaine, l'un d'entre vous.
Peut être toi, juste là, derrière l'écran.
Tenez vous au courant demain sur les réseaux sociaux: sur Twitter, sur Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat,
je vous annoncerez comment on va faire pour jouer à qui va participer à la mentalisation de vendredi.
En parlant de réseaux sociaux, n'hésitez pas à ajouter Yacine sur les réseaux sociaux, parce qu'il poste cool et poste souvent.
Vous pouvez également laisser un petit commentaire pour nous dire ce que vous en avez penser.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, vous pouvez laisser un diabolique, et vaudouisant...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner avant de partir, puisque le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !